a show of force by Congolese soldiers as
they take us to their defense positions
against the Allied democratic forces
rebel group or ADF deep in the forest
the Army has sent five generals to
command 22,000 soldiers in the fight
against an estimated 2,000 ADF fighters
on the run in the jungle
the generals discussed strategy and
visit troops on the front line we are
dealing with terrorists they are now
unable to fight the military so they go
back and kill civilians but will not
stop until they leave United Nations
officials say the rebels are holding
hundreds of hostages kidnapped in the
last year and a half the area was formed
in western Uganda in the 1990s with the
aim of creating an Islamic state the
Ugandan army forced the fighters to move
to neighbouring DRC where they were
initially tolerated the aims of ADF
aren't clear but they attacked and
robbed villages like this one with guns
and machetes
to cut their victims to pieces this is
the last village before you get to areas
in the forest where the military is
fighting ADF people here have told us
that they had been terrorized by the
group for so long and army commanders
we've talked to say that soldiers have
been able to push the group farther into
the forest they have killed many of them
including some commanders another group
is very much on the run some Congolese
say the military is using a local armed
group called my mine to help fight the
ADF army commanders we talked to denied
that some mai-mai factions have been
accused of human rights abuses in remote
villages they control this woman says a
mime i arrested her and five other women
who were accused of attempting to poison
someone in the community I told him I
did not try to poison anyone but they
will not believe me they were beating us
badly I decided to run they shot me
doctors had to amputate one of my legs
UN peacekeepers say they have increased
patrols in villages and are providing
tactical and logistical support to the
Congolese army - you got these ATF
rubles sometimes attack villages that
are close to military bases and
positions what surprising people think
security forces aren't doing enough
either they are disorganized or their
strategy to defeat ATF is not working
nearly 1,000 Congolese villagers have
been killed by ADF since the military
offensive against the group started in
October victims we talked to say they
just want the attacks to stop Catholics
or al jazeera bene in the eastern
Democratic Republic of Congo